oceans are critical to keeping our
global ecosystem in balance
they are home to hundreds of thousands
of species many of which are under
threat there are millions of people
whose day-to-day survival depends on
their continued health
[Music]
my connection to the ocean is rooted in
my love of surfing
it's Tommy that the see is a dynamic and
powerful force one that demands respect
the fisherman I'm studying understand
this better than anyone
I'm Shannon Switzer Swanson I'm a marine
social ecologist and a National
Geographic Explorer my research focuses
on marine conservation in Indonesia's
vanga archipelago
I'm spending a year embedded in several
communities living with families to
observe their daily fishing practices
it's a complicated web of ancient
practices and modern pressures
I'm trying to understand what motivates
fishing families to use more sustainable
methods that are safer for both them and
the reef I'm curious why some fishermen
have developed a strong conservation
ethic while others have not papa Adam
comes from a long line of traditionally
nomadic fishermen called the Bajau he
specializes in spear fishing and
catching aquarium fish using an air
compressor to breathe
if not done conscientiously fishing can
damage coral diminish important fish
populations and potentially upset the
reef ecosystem
[Music]
how the atom sells the aquarium fish she
catches two buyers
over a quarter of the tens of millions
of aquarium fish caught annually come
from Indonesia
[Music]
Papa Adam also catches fish to feed his
family and to sell as food
he and many like him supply Indonesia's
bustling fish markets
this community is beyond gracious
they've not only welcomed me into their
daily working lives but into their homes
as well
these fishing families way of life is
special rooted in a connection to the
ocean thousands of years old
a relationship that needs to flourish
for thousands more
you
you